[Music]
late last week as we covered on this
show senator ted cruz
just talked about came under intense
scrutiny and backlash after it was
revealed
that he had traveled with his family to
cancun during the winter storm disaster
in his state
this is a huge controversy for reasons
that nobody could ever quite explain
even after he revised his plans and
returned home the outrage had not quite
abated
uh in fact the media was tracking cruz's
family his wife and daughters now
in cancun a new york post headline
announced quote ted cruz's family seen
soaking up the cancun sun while texas
shivers
i have to admit that's pretty outrageous
you know ted cruz's daughters
should be back in texas working to fix
the power grid damn lazy kids nowadays
back in my day when there was an outage
my parents had me climb up the pole to
fix the power lines myself that had to
do without shoes too
uphill both ways but these are softer
and more delicate times i suppose
anyway the pr crisis for cruz became an
opportunity for others like
representative alexandria casio cortez
who
shortly after cancungate went viral
announced
that she would be traveling to texas to
help out herself
totally coincidental timing i'm sure as
the local abc affiliate in houston
reported aoc
quote toward houston storm damage now
why did a representative from new york
need to fly down to a city a different
state
1600 miles away to tour the storm damage
while the cynical among us might
theorize that this was nothing more than
a glorified
instagram photo shoot in fairness though
she did more than tour the damage
there's also video of her lifting
packages of water bottles and
putting them in people's trunks which is
also nice
but again the cynical those darn cynical
people
might say that the workers and
volunteers taking care of the mess down
at houston
really didn't need a high-profile
politician from up north to fly down
to help pick up water bottles i mean
there's no practical advantage to her
presence there
she brings media she brings probably
extra security
other logistical concerns that vastly
outweigh the benefit
of having her there to put water bottles
in people's trunks and make concerned
facial expressions
while looking at the storm damage i just
i doubt that any emergency worker or
charity volunteer has ever been in the
middle of a crisis
and then stopped to look around and said
to themselves you know what we really
need here you know we need we need a
famous politician trailed by a line of
journalists with cameras
that will make everything run smoother
if aoc really wanted to provide extra
manpower she could have delegated she
could have sent some people down
or help to recruit locals she did help
raise money for the storm relief which
is good
but the part where she shows up in
person to lift up water bottles on
camera
that's where you might suspect that
there's more to this than her passion
for charity work
at least a cynical person might think
that let's be fair though she didn't
just tour the storm damage or put water
bottles and trunks
she also of course found a microphone
and a podium to give a speech
and here's some of that you know we
really need to make sure that
we're getting food and assistance to
people across the state as is mentioned
here at the food at the houston food
bank no questions are asked
so you come up and you need help you do
not have to prove
a damn thing
in the houston food bank if you are
documented undocumented
no matter what your income no matter
your housing status
you can get help here which is one of
the reasons why we are so proud to
support the houston food bank
because we don't because we want to help
everybody
you need it we'll be there gee you know
it it really looks and sounds like this
woman flew down to texas in the middle
of a natural disaster to pose for
cameras
and deliver a stump speech i mean did
it's the houston
food bank do they need a congresswoman
from new york
to come and speak for them are they not
capable of doing that themselves
what she just said there is was there no
one who actually works at the food bank
no local person that could have gotten
on camera and said all that that they
need to fly herd in to say that
it looks like she was taking advantage
it looks and sounds that way because
that's exactly what she did
it's the same people person who um
claimed that ted cruz was trying to kill
her
which by the way what are you doing
going down to texas ted cruz is there he
didn't leave
you said he's trying to kill you putting
her out but her i guess she's
more more courage from this woman
putting her taking her life into her
hands like that
there's also the same woman who claimed
that she had a near-death experience in
the riots even though the rioters never
came near her or entered the building
she was in
she has a history of dramatically
exploiting crises for political gain
and if you have any lingering doubts and
think that maybe she really went to
texas to perform charity work on camera
for entirely benevolent reasons then
consider that communities in her own
state her own city
were devastated over the summer by blm
rioting and she never showed up to help
the victims there
much less give give speeches advocating
for them
she chose texas for a reason
by the way she's also been clear that
people shouldn't be traveling during the
pandemic number one
and people actually shouldn't be
traveling by plane at all because it's
destroying the environment and bringing
mankind to the brink of extinction
it's actually causing exactly the kinds
of weather events that that devastated
texas
according to her you think this would be
all the more reason to not
fly to texas when there is clearly no
practical benefit
to her physical presence in the states
but it wasn't about the practical
benefit except in the sense that
political benefits are
practical now i don't mean to pick on
aoc here
she is so transparently opportunistic
that it's hard not to pick on her but
it's not like she's the first politician
to swoop down into a crisis like this
she wasn't the only politician in the
you know getting in the way down there
in texas even ted cruz
showed up to carry water bottles around
after he got all that guff for trying to
leave town
it's a pretty standard political
procedure uh using a natural disaster as
a campaign event
politicians have been doing that forever
of course but that doesn't make it any
better
ted cruz had it right the first time
it's better for these people to just get
out of the way
than for them to show up for the photo
shoot and that's why
aoc is cancelled am i really canceling
her for doing charity work
yes i am absolutely because it's not
about the charity
at all and if you don't see that if
you're too dumb to see that then well
you're canceled too
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated